Bçik 9. sınıf önce cof okunan YouTube'un
en büyükf kanalına hepiniz hoş geldiniz.
Zed öğretmenleri ile beraber yaptığımız
okula destek kampımızın bugün geldik kaç
21 günne pardon 22 gününe. Bugün sizinle
beraber ekonomik faaliyetler ve etkileri
konusunu öğreneceğiz. Ve artık bu
ünitemiz bitecek. Bundan sonra artık
doğal afetler ünitesine geçeceğiz. Hiç
uzatmıyoruz. Ne diyoruz o zaman? Yunus
hocayla bir defa öğren. Bir daha asla
unutma. Zedua ile eğitim her yerde.
Evet. Konumuz ekonomik faaliyetler ve
etkileri. Zeduva.com sitesinden ücretsiz
bir şekilde bu PDF'i böyle
indirebilirsiniz gençler. Zedua
öğretmenleri olarak diğer branşlarda da
artık matematikçinin gelmesiyle beraber
hepsini tamamladık. Zedua öğretmenleri
olarak bütün branşlarda bu anlatımları
yapıyoruz size. Diğer öğretmenleri de
takip etmeyi unutmayın gençler. Tamam.
Gelelim şimdi ekonomik faaliyetlere.
Gençler bakın ekonomik faaliyetleri
üretim, dağıtım ve tüketim olmak üzere
üçe ayırıyoruz. Üç temel unsurumuz var
bizim. Nedir bu üretim? Bak tanımına
bak. Mal ve hizmetlerin bir dizi
işlemden geçirildikten sonra insanların,
bak şurası önemli, altını buranın çiz.
İnsanların kullanabileceği duruma
getirilmesi. Mal ve hizmeti aldık.
çeşitli faaliyetlerden geçirdik ve artık
bunu bir insanın kullanabileceği duruma
getirdiysek biz buna üretim diyoruz. Ve
bu üretimi şöyle bakın birincil
faaliyetler ve ikincil faaliyetler diye
ikiye ayırıyoruz. Üretimdeki bu kısmı bu
ne? Birincil faaliyetten kastımız
gençler tarım, hayvan, orman, maden.
Dikkat et. Daha çok böyle hammadde elde
etmeye yönelik şeyler bunlar. Tarım
yapıyorum, hammadde aldım. Ormandan
hammadde aldım. Bunlar daha çok böyle
hammadde elde etmeye yönelikse birincil
üretim diyoruz biz buna. İkinci üretimde
ise işin içine sanayi kısmı giriyor. Bu
sefer bak oradan aldığımız hammaddeyi
sanayide işledik. Enerjide, inşaatta
yani başka bir şekilde aldık hammaddeyi.
Onunla beraber bir ev yaptık. İkincil
bir versiyonuna getirdiysek buna da
ikincil faaliyetler deniyor. Üretimi
ikiye ayırdık. Birincil faaliyetler,
ikincil faaliyetler diye. Çok önemli
değil. Ama burada temel olarak şurada
üretimin ne anlama geldiğini öğrettim
sana. Ha ne yaptım? Birincil ya da
ikincil olsun. Bunu aldım. İnsanların
kullanabileceği bir duruma getirdiysem
biz buna ne dedik o zaman? Buna üretim
dedik. Yani malı ürettik. İnsanların
kullanabileceği duruma getirdik. E şimdi
tamam ben bu kalemi insanların ya da
dünya haritaları diyelim. Biz bu dünya
haritalarını insanların kullanabileceği
duruma getirdim. Öğrencilerin
kullanabileceği duruma getirdim ben bu
dünya haritaları kitabımı. E şimdi ne
olacak? E bunu benim tüketiciye yollamam
gerekiyor. Değil mi? O da tüketecek.
İşte burada bakın üretilen ve mal ve
hizmetin bir yerden başka bir yere
taşınması faaliyetine ikincil kısma
geldik. Dağıtıma ihtiyacımız var.
Ürettim. Bunu dağıtmam lazım. Nasıl
dağıtıyorum bunu? E bu kırtasiyelere
gidiyor. Bizim satış noktalarımız
oluyor. O kırtasiyelere gidiyor. Bak bir
dağıtım ya da bunu işte çeşitli
sitelerden satışını yapıyoruz. Bu bir
dağıtıma giriyor. Dağıtımda ürettiğimiz
bu malı tüketiciye taşınması anlamına
geliyor. Ne yaptım şimdi? Malı ürettim.
Dağıtımda bunu verdim bir kargoya da
satış noktasına kırtasiyeye verdim.
3üncü kısma geldik. Bu sefer de tüketim
bu sefer de bu alıcıya sana ulaştı. Yani
mal ve hizmetlerin tüketiciler
tarafından kullanılmasını ifade ediyor.
Sana ulaştı. Sen de bunu aldın,
kullandın, tükettin. Yani ekonomik
faaliyetleri biz ne yaptık? Üretim,
dağıtım ve tüketim olarak ayırdık.
Buradaki mantığımız bu. Bunlar gençler
birbirini etkiliyorlar. Bunu unutmayın.
Nasıl yani hocam? Şöyle, bir ürünün
tüketimi artıyorsa üretimi de
artabiliyor. Nasıl yani hocam? Mesela
kahve kültürü dünyada yayılan,
popülerleşen bir kültür. Popüler hale
geldi. Yani elimize bir kahve alıp bu
kahveyle beraber dolaşmak, günü kahveyle
açmak. Avrupalılarda daha fazlaydı ama
ülkemizde de mesela son yıllarda bu
arttı. Kahve, kahve satan yerler
popülerleşti. Düşünün bunu. Şimdi
tüketimi arttı. Geçmişte kahve bu kadar
tüketilmiyordu ama bu popüler kültürle
beraber kahve tüketimi artınca bu sefer
kahve üretimi de arttı. Kahveyi üreten
çok fazla ülke yoktu. Genellikle bu
tropikal bölgelerde yetişiyor gençler.
Ekvator'a yakın bölgelerde öyle düşünün.
Etiyopya'ydı buranın anavatanı kahve
üretiminin. Ama sonra birçok yere
yayıldı oradaki ülkelerde. Yani tüketim
artınca üretim de artabilir. Bunu
unutmayın. Tamam. Üretim artınca bunlar
hep birbirini etkiliyor gençler. Üretim
artınca bir yerde tüketim de artabilir.
Nasıl yani hocam? Bir mal çok fazla
üretiliyorsa, çok fazla sektörde, çok
fazla insan tarafından, fabrikada
üretiliyorsa bu sefer bu malın
maliyetlerin işte e buradaki şeyi
azalıyor. Çok fazla mal varsa bu ürünün
fiyatı azalabiliyor. 200 liraysa 100
liraya düşebiliyor. Bunu birçok kişi
ürettiğinde. Şimdi bu sefer 100 liraya
düşünce tüketimi artabilir bu ürünün.
Üretim fazla, fiyat düştü, tüketimi
etkiledi. Bakın dağıtımda bunların
hepsini etkileyebiliyor. Mesela geçmiş
yıllarda dağıtım bu kadar kaliteli ve
hızlı değildi. Şu an dağıtım o kadar
hızlandı ki insanlar daha fazla tüketir
hale geldi. Mesela bu internet siteleri
açıldı değil mi? Bu internet siteleri ne
yaptılar? Kendi dağıtım ağlarını
kurdular ve bunu hızlı yaptılar. İki
günde, bir günde hemen aynı gün direkt
kapına gelebiliyor. Böyle olunca tüketim
de arttı. İnsanlar ya alayım hemen nasıl
da olsa gelecek dediler. Daha kolay
alabilir hale geldiler. Ya şimdi ben bir
giysi alacağım ya da ne bileyim bu
kitabı alacağım mesela. Şimdi gideyim
bunu kırtasiye bulayım. O kırtasiyede
var mı yok mu 2ü gün sürer belki. Onun
için yolumu değiştireceğim. Ama şimdi ne
yapıyorum? İnternete giriyorum. Nasıl
olsa bugün kapımda diyorum. Tık
tıklıyorum. Alabilmem tüketebilmem
hızlandı. Dikkat ederseniz dağıtım
tüketimi de arttırdı. E dağıtım o zaman
tüketimi arttırdıysa daha hızlı
tüketiliyorsa o zaman üretimi de
arttıracak. daha hızlı üretim yapmak
zorunda kalacağız. Dağıtım ikisini de
etkiledi. Bakın bu dağıtımın hızlı
değişimi, hızlanması maliyetlerini
düşürdü. Maliyetler tabii her geçen yıl
artabiliyor ama genel olarak 50 liraya
gidecek bir ürünü 30 liraya gidebilir
hale getirdi şirketler. Çünkü çok hızlı
orada devir daimi olmaya başladı.
Sürümden kazanmaya başladı. Bakın bu
sefer üretim etkilendi, dağıtım
etkilendi, hepsi etkilendi. Dağıtımda
mesela teknolojik gelişmeler yaşanıyor.
Bu teknolojik gelişmeler tüketim üretimi
de arttırıyor. Geçmişte soğuk hava
depoları yoktu arabalarda, araçlarda o
kadar hızlı dağıtım yapılamıyordu.
Teknolojinin gelişmesiyle soğuk hava
depoları şeklinde kamyonlar oldu. Mesela
bazı ürünler çok uzak yerlere
götürülebildi. Dağıtım gelişti onlar
için. Bu sefer üretimi de arttı. O
ürünlerin tüketimi de arttı. Dağıtım
bütün sektörler demek ki gençler
buradaki üretim tüketimi
etkileyebiliyor. Dağıtımı
etkileyebiliyor. Dağıtım bunların
hepsini etkileyebiliyor. Tamam. Burada
şu var. Bu ekonomik faaliyetleri
etkileyen doğal faktörler. Bir de beşeri
faktörler. Biri bize doğal faktör dediği
zaman ne diyorduk? Doğada olacak, fiziki
olacak. Bakın insan olmayacak içinde.
Beşeri faktörleri dediğinde insan
olacak. Şimdi bunları ezberlememiz mi
gerekiyor? Hayır. Yorumlayacaksın.
Yorumlayalım. ekonomik faaliyetleri,
iklim koşulları nasıl etkiler? Burada
gençler bu PDF'in burasında bunlarla
alakalı örnekler var. Biz şimdi oradaki
örnekleri değil de ben sana anlatımımı
yapacağım. Sen oradan okumak istiyorsan
oku. Ekonomik faaliyetleri iklim
koşulları nasıl etkiler? Düşünelim
şimdi. Tamam mı? İklimden kastımız ne?
Sıcaklık, yağış, nem? He mesela düşün.
İklim koşulları üretimi nasıl
etkileyebilir? Örnek ver. Hayvancılık
mesela iklim koşullarının iyi olduğu
yerlerde, bol çayırların olduğu yerlerde
büyükbaş hayvan bakmak çok daha kolay
olur değil mi? Üretim artabilir. Bak
gördün mü? Ya da dağıtımı nasıl
etkileyebilir iklim koşulları? E hocam
çok kar yağan yerlerde, Doğu Anadolu
gibi kışların sert geçtiği yerlerde,
yolların buz olduğu yerlerde o zaman
dağıtım sekteye uğrayabilir. Buna çok
örnek verebiliriz gençler. Karın yağdığı
yerde ulaşım yapmak zordur. E ne olacak?
Dağıtım etkilendi mi? Bakın etkilendi.
Tüketim de etkilenir. Ya buna binlerce
örnek verilebilir. Buna ne desen oluyor?
Mesela kendimiz yorumlamayı öğreniyoruz.
Şu an yorumlayacaksın. Nasıl? Mesela
iklim koşullarının çok soğuk olduğu
kutuplara yakın bir yerde yaşıyorum. Bu
benim üretimimi etkiler mi? Evet. Mesela
tarım yapamam ben burada. Bak üretimim
etkilendi. Tüketimimi etkiler mi? Evet.
Ben tarım ürünlerine ulaşamam. E bak
tarım ürünleri tüketemedim. Ne
tüketebilirim? Eee orada yok. Buzlarla
kaplı her taraf. Ne yapacağım o zaman?
Balık. Balık yiyebilirim. Balık
tüketirim. Bak benim hangi ürünü
tüketeceğimi de etkiledi mi? İktlim
koşulları. Evet. Tarım ürünü
üretemeyeceğimi etkiledi. Balık üretimi
yapabilirsin dedi. Bak üretimimi
etkiledi. Tüketimimde balık
tüketebilirsin dedi. Etkiledi. Dağılışı
dağıtımı etkiledi. E buzun üstünde nasıl
dağıtım yapacağım? Etkilendi. İklim
koşulları. Bakın birçok şeyi etkiledi.
İklim koşulları. Benim mesela
tüketimimde hangi giysilerin olacağını
etkiler. Soğuk yerlerde sadece mont
giyerken işte soğuk şeyler giyerken,
kalın şeyler giyerken ekvatörde
yaşıyorsam o zaman ben hangi ürünlere
daha çok tişörte, şorta, terliye
yöneleceğim? Ekvator'da bot
satamayacağız. Ne oldu? İklim koşulu
benim hangi ürünü tüketeceğimi belirledi
mi? Belirledi. Bu böyle yorum yapıyorsun
işte. Toprak ve bitki örtüsü. Bitki
örtüsü. Az önce söyledik mesela. Tabii
ki iklim bitki örtüsünü etkiliyor. Bitki
örtüsünün gür olduğu yerlerde mesela
Erzurum Kars çevresinde en son gezimiz
Karsaydı bizim değil mi? Kars'a gittik.
Kars'ta ne vardı? Hep hayvancılık
ürünleri vardı. Kaşar satıyorlardı. İşte
kavurma satıyorlardı. Bal satıyorlardı.
Hep hayvancılık ürünleri vardı. Niye?
Oranın iklim koşullarından dolayı
çayırlar gelişiyor. İşte çiçekler var.
arıcılık yapılabiliyor. Çayırlardan
büyükbaş hayvancılık yapılıyor. Büyükbaş
hayvancılık yapınca kaşar peynir üretimi
yapılıyor. Bakın ne oldu? İktlim bitki
örtüsü. Oradaki bitki örtüsü benim
üretimimi etkiledi. Hep peynir ürünleri
ürettim. Oradaki tüketimi de etkiliyor.
İnsanlar daha çok kaşar tüketiyor,
peynir tüketiyor, hayvansal ürünler
tüketiyorlar. Üretim tüketim dağıtımı
etkiledi mi? Dağıtımı nasıl etkiler
hocam? Dağıtım da dedik. Mesela örnek
verin. Bitki örtüsü. Bitki örtüsünün gür
olduğu ekvatordayız. E her tarafta
ormanlar var. E dağıtım zor olacak. Yol
açmak zor olacak. Yol açamayacaksın.
Değil mi? Bakın etkilenmiş oldu. Demek
ki hepsini etkiledi. E hocam yeryüzü
şekilleri, yeryüzü şekillerinin en
gebeli dağlık olduğu bir yer düşünelim.
Üretimi nasıl etkileyebilir? E hocam
dağlık engebeli her taraf. Benim burada
üretim yapmam daha zor olacak. Makine
kullanımım zor olacak. Etkiledi. Bakın
dağıtımı nasıl etkileyebilir. E hocam
ben buraya yol yapmak, ulaşım yapmak zor
olacak. Maliyetli olacak. Belki de
yapamayacağım engebeli olduğu için. Bak
dağıtım etkilendi. Düz olan yerlerde
dağıtım daha kolay olacak. Ne yapıyorum?
Bunu ezberlemiyorsun. Bunu yorum
yapıyorsun. Nasıl? Sana sorulduğunda
aşağıdakilerden hangisi üretim, dağıtım
tüketimi ya da ekonomik faaliyetleri
etkileyen doğal faktörlerden değildir?
Sordum. İklim, yer şekilleri, bitki
örtüsü, sermaye. Ha, iklim, yer
şekilleri, bitki örtüsü hepsi doğal.
Dışarıda insan, insan değil bunlar ama
sermaye insanla alakalı. sermaye
beşeriği. Az sonra da beşerileri
göreceğiz merak etme. Der ki, eee, iklim
koşulları ekonomik faaliyetleri nasıl
etkilemektedir? Bunu yorumlayınız. Sen
de yorum yapacaksın az önce yaptığım
gibi. Mesela su kaynakları, iklim, eee,
ekonomik faaliyetleri nasıl etkiler?
Yorumlayınız dedi. He, su kaynakları,
Bakalım. Üretim etkiler mi su
kaynakları? Evet hocam. Tarım
alanlarında tarım için bana su lazım.
Suyun bol olduğu yerlerde tarım
yapabilirim. Maliyeti düşük bir şekilde
yapabilirim. Etkiledi. Bakın dağıtımı
nasıl etkileyebilir hocam? Suyun olduğu,
denizlerin olduğu yerlerde gemiyle
dağıtım yaparız. Gemi ulaşımı gelişir.
Bu avantaj. Evet. Ya da akarsular, bazı
akarsular ulaşıma elverişli avantaj.
Dağıtım yaptı. Bakın üretimi başka nasıl
etkileyebilir? Bazı fabrikalar, sanayi
kuruluşları gençler suyu kullanır.
Mesela suyu, suyu, domatesleri,
patatesleri temizlemek için ciddi su
kullanır. Ya da demir çelik fabrikaları
su kullanımı yapıyor orada soğutmak
için. Çok ciddi su kullanımı yapıyor.
Bakın etkiledi. Tamam. Peki hocam,
hammadde ve enerji kaynakları nasıl
etkiler? En önemlilerinden bir tanesidir
bu gençler. Mesela hammadde. Hammaddenin
olduğu yerlerde üretim oluyor. Nasıl
yani hocam? Şimdi zeytin bir hammadde.
Tamam mı? Zeytin ağacı. Zeytinyağı
fabrikası kuracağız. Nereye kurarsın?
Zeytin üretiminin yani hammaddenin
olduğu yere kurarsın, değil mi?
Fabrikayı. Hammadde benim üretimimi
etkiler. Hammaddenin bol olduğu
yerlerde, zeytin ağaçlarının bol olduğu,
hammaddesinin bol olduğu yerlerde ben
zeytin üretimi yaparım. Bu da benim
üretimimi etkiler. Enerji kaynakları
üretimimi, tüketimimi, ekonomimi
etkiliyor. Mesela gençler taş kömürü
yatakları var. Zonguldak ve çevresinde
taş kömürü yatakları var. Şimdi orada
taş kömürü olunca enerji var. Yani
enerji olunca ne yapmışlar? E burada taş
kömürü varsa biz buraya demir demir
getirelim. Dışarıdan demir çelik
fabrikası yapalım demişler. Bak ne oldu?
Enerjiden dolayı demir çelik fabrikası
kuruldu oraya. Üretim etkilendi mi?
Etkilendi. E şimdi buralara demir çelik
fabrikası kurulacaksa demişler ya buraya
tren hattı ya da liman kuralım demişler.
Tren yolu yapalım demişler. Bakın
dağıtım kısmı için gelişmeler yapılmış.
Dağıtım gelişmiş bu bölgede ve bu
bölgede yine buna yönelik tüketim de
artacak. İnsanlar buraya gelecek.
İnsanlar burada kalabalıklaşacak.
Tüketim artacak. Bakın hammaddede enerji
kaynakları da üretim, dağıtım tüketimi,
ekonomik faaliyetleri etkiliyor. Şu an
biz neyi gördük? Ekonomik faaliyetleri
etkileyen doğal faktörleri gördük.
Bunları ezberlemene gerek yok. Sana
sorulduğunda ya ekonomiyi, ekonomik
faaliyetleri etkileyen doğal faktörler
nelerdir? Düşüneceksin abi. Ekonomiyi
iklim etkileyebilir. Ekonomik
faaliyetleri. Bak bu doğal. Su
kaynakları doğal. Enerji kaynakları,
hammadde kaynakları doğal değil mi?
Bunların hepsi doğal. Şimdi bir de
gelelim beşeri olanlara. Nerede burası?
Hah, şimdi de bunu öğreneceğiz. Bu sefer
bunu bakın üretimi etkileyen, dağıtımı
etkileyen, tüketimi etkileyen şekilde
ayırdık. Şimdi de bunun yorumunu yapman
lazım. Üretimi etkileyen bu sefer beşeri
unsurlar. İşin içinde ne olacak? İnsan
olacak. Yani birincisi iş gücü ve
özellikleri. Üretim diyor bana. Üretim
yapacağım. Mesela bir fabrika kuracağım.
Bana ne lazım? İş gücü lazım. Hatta bunu
kendi yayınımız üzerinden anlatayım
size. Seneye gençler Zeduava
öğretmenleri olarak öğretmenler olarak
toplandık. Biliyorsunuz Zedua
öğretmenlerini hepimizi tanıyorsunuz.
Kendi yayınımızı kuracağız. Başka
yayınlarla uğraşmayalım. İletişimsizlik
oluyor. Birbirimizi anlayamıyoruz ve bir
türlü işleri yürütemiyoruz. Dedik ki ya
öğretmenler olarak oturalım kendi
yayınımızı kuralım. Şimdi o zaman biz
bir üretim yapacağız değil mi? Bir
dağıtım yapacağız Zeduava yayınları
olarak. Bir de tüketim yapacağız. Şimdi
Zeduava yayınları olarak burada ne var?
Bizi etkileyen beşeri unsurlar olacak.
Bunlardan üretimimizi etkileyecek. Bu
daha anlaşılır olsun diye kendi
yayınımızdan anlatıyorum. Mesela bizim
burada üretim yaparken şimdi 10.
sınıftayken size yazılıları genel tekrar
yaptığımız, yazılı notların içinde
olduğu, yazılı örneklerin içinde olduğu
bir tane coğrafya kitabı yaptığımızı
düşünelim. Tamam mı? Ben burada üretimi
yaparken iş gücüne ihtiyacım olacak.
Benim değil mi? İnsana ihtiyacım olacak.
Bu kitaplar yazılırken bana birileri
destek olacak. Bu kitaplar matbaada
basılacak. Matbaa süreci olacak. Bütün
bunlarda bana iş gücü ve özelliği lazım
olacak. Yani üretim için bana iş gücü
lazım. İş gücü beşeri bir unsur mu?
Evet. İş gücü bulamazsam üretimimi
yapamam. Üretimimi etkiledi mi? iş gücü
ve özelliği etkiledi. İkincisi, bu
yayını kurabilmemiz için bizim
öğretmenler olarak neye ihtiyacımız var?
Sermayeye. Sermayemiz olmasaydı bizim bu
yayını kuramazdık. E para yok ortada.
Bunun kağıdı alınacak, basımı yapılacak.
Bunun bir maliyeti var, dizgicisi var,
stüdyo kurulacak. Bir sürü insan burada
dağıtım busu çalışacak. Bütün bunları
karşılayabilmemiz için bizim neye
ihtiyacımız var? Sermayeye ihtiyacımız
var. Bütün öğretmenler için ne
yapacağız? para toplayacağız ortaya. Bir
sermaye koyacağız ki yayını üretimi
yapabilelim. Demek ki benim üretim
yapabilmem için bu Zeduava yayınlarında
sermaye ortaya koymam gerekiyor. Bir iş
gücü üretimi etkiledi mi? Etkiledi.
Sermaye. Paranın varlığı üretimi
etkiledi mi? Etkiledi. Başka? Teknolojik
gelişmeler üretimi etkiler. Mesela
teknolojik gelişmelerde matba olmasaydı
üretim yapabilecek miydik?
Yapamayacaktık. Değil mi? Matbaanın
varlığı bu iş için başka işler için
başka makineler düşünün. Teknolojik
gelişmeler arttığı için üretimde arttı.
Matbaalar çok daha kaliteli matbaalar
var. Daha güzel basılacak kitap gibi
düşünün. Yani teknolojik gelişme
üretimimizi etkiledi. Ekonomi
politikaları üretimi etkiler mi? Evet.
Mesela şimdi Zeduava yayınlarını
kuruyoruz. E ülkenin de içinden geçtiği
ekonomik olarak sıkıntılı dönemlerden
geçiyoruz. İşte doların çıkışı var değil
mi? Dolar çıkıyor mu? Ya şu kağıdı
alabileceğiz mi? Bu kağıtları
alamayacağız mı? İşte Zedua yayınlarında
10 kişi çalıştıracağız. Bu 10 kişinin
maaşını ödeyebileceğiz mi? Ülkenin
ekonomi politikası enflasyonu arttırmaya
yönelik olursa biz ne yapacağız? O zaman
o kağıdı şimdiden alalım. Yaza
bırakmayalım. Yaza belki de kağıt
fiyatları uçacak. Bak ülkedeki ekonomi
politikası benim üretimimi. Hat bunu
şimdiden aylar öncesinde düşünmeme neden
oldu mu? Neden oldu. Bak demek ki
ülkenin ekonomi politikaları üretimi
etkiliyormuş. Tamam. Ulaşım. E ulaşım da
üretimi etkileyecek. Nereye gidiyoruz
mesela gençler biz? Şimdi ben şimdi
İstanbul'da oturuyorum. Taşınacağım
seneye. Yayın kurulacak ve böyle Kasım,
Aralık, Ocak gibi Ankara'ya taşınacağım.
Neden Ankara? Çünkü Ankara orta noktada,
o noktada yapacağımız basım her tarafa
rahatlıkla ulaşabilecek. Ulaşım da benim
üretimimi etkileyecek. Yani ulaşım
koşullarının varlığından dolayı
Ankara'da yapıyoruz bunu. Gidip
Çanakkale'de yaparsak Türkiye'nin bir
ucunda. Çanakkale'den başka yerlere bu
kitapları yollamak ne olacak? Maliyeti
arttıracak. Arttırmasın diye. Üretimim
zarar görmesin diye ulaşımın olduğu
Ankara'da yapacağız. Şimdi neyi gördük?
Üretimi etkileyen faktörleri gördük.
Sana sorulduğunda işte sermaye üretimi
etkiler mi? etkiler. Şundan dolayı
etkiler diyeceksin. Ben de bunu sana
kuracağımız Zedua yayınları üzerinden
mantığını anlatıyorum. Peki hocam bu
Zedua yayınlarıyla biz kitapları üretimi
yaptık. Bastık ne yapacağız? Dağıtım da
yapmamız lazım değil mi? Bu dağıtımı
yaparken e ne olacak? Ulaşım bizim için
önemli. Ulaşım. O yüzden Ankara'ya
gittik. E bak dağıtımımızı etkiledi. Bu
bizim dağıtımımızı etkiledi. Oradan her
tarafa rahatlıkla yollayacağız bunu.
Teknolojik gelişmeler. E kargo
sistemleri o kadar fazla gelişti ki biz
kargo sistemleri rahatlıkla geliştiği
için expressler falan var. Hızlıca
Ankara'dan daha merkezi bir konumdan
rahatlıkla bunu yollayabileceğiz.
Teknoloji geliştiği için
yollayabiliyoruz. Ama bakın başka modern
pazarlama teknikleri. Gençler pazarlama
teknikleri de ulaşımın içine girer.
Ulaşımda sadece şunu düşünmeyeceksiniz.
İşte kamyona yükledik. yolladık
kitapları. Hayır, bu bir ulaşım değil.
Benim mesela Instagram sayfam var,
YouTube sayfam var. Bu videoları
yaparken ne yapıyoruz? Kendi
ürünlerimizi de aynı zamanda pazarlama
yapıyoruz, reklam yapıyoruz. Değil mi?
Instagram'dan reklam yapabiliyoruz biz
kendi ürünlerimizi ve bu ürünlerle
beraber yani biz ne yapıyoruz aslında
öğretmenler olarak? Modern pazarlama
teknikleri yapıyoruz. Aslında şu an
yayını kurana kadar bizim yaptığımız iş
neydi biliyor musunuz? Hem öğretmenlik
yapıyoruz biz. öğretmenlik yaparken
dağıtım da yapıyoruz. Çünkü modern bir
şekilde, modern pazarlama yöntemleriyle
öğretmenliğimizi birleştirmiştik. Şimdi
yayını kurarak üretimi de
birleştiriyoruz. Böylece üretim, dağıtım
ve tüketim kısmındaki o ana noktaları
birleştirip öğretmenler olarak daha
güçlü hale geliyoruz. Şu an ne oldu?
Modern pazarlama teknikleri demek ki.
Yani bu reklamlar, tanıtımlar, bunlar da
nereye giriyormuş? Dağıtım kısmına
giriyor. Tamam. Buna biz peki burada ne
yapacağız? Zaten biz kendimiz Instagram
sayfalarımız var, YouTube sayfalarımız
var. Modern pazarlama tekniklerine biz
zaten hakimiz. Bunu da yapıyoruz.
Dağıtımda bu da var mıymış? Varmış. Bu
da etkiliyor muymuş? Etkiliyormuş. İnsan
kaynakları. E bu dağıtımı yapabilmek
için insana ihtiyaç var. Bu dağıtımı
pazarlamayı yapabilmek için insanlara
ihtiyacımız var. Bu da dağıtımı etkiledi
mi? Etkiledi. E yer şekilleri
özellikleri. Biz şimdi Ankara'dan
yollayacağız kargoyu. Hadi bakalım.
Doğuya gidecek. Yer şekilleri engebeliği
olduğu için zorlanabilecek dağıtım
kısmı, yer şekilleri dağıtımı etkiledi
mi? Etkiledi. Ama Konya'ya Ankara'dan
yollarken dümdüz yollar sorun
yaşamayacağız gibi. Başka iletişim
gençler iletişim de dağıtım içindedir.
Unutmayın telefon bak bir iletişim
aracı. Telefon dağıtım içerisine girer.
Bunu unutma. İletişim sektörleri
geliştiği için ülkemizde dağıtım da
gelişmiş oldu. İletişim de var.
Telefonlarımız da var. Tamam. Geldik.
Bütün hepsini yaptık. Üretimi yaptık,
dağıtımı yaptık yayınımızda. E bir de
şimdi 3üncü kısım ne? Ekonomik
faaliyetlerde tüketim kısmı. Şimdi bu
ürün sana gelecek. Bu tüketimi ne
etkiliyor? Senin bu ürünü alırken bu
ürünü buradaki tüketimi etkileyen şeyler
neler? Bir bakın ihtiyaçlar. Senin buna
ihtiyacın var mı? Mesela dünya artıları
kitabını yaptık. Seneye bastık. Sana
bunu ulaştırdık. Bunu tüketirken birinci
önemli olan ne? Senin buna ihtiyacın var
mı? İhtiyaçlar çok önemli. Sen şimdi
geldin işte sayısal 11. sınıf
öğrencisisin. E sen tutup 9. sınıf
coğrafya kitabını almazsın değil mi?
Neden? Çünkü senin buna ihtiyacın yok.
Ha demek ki tüketimi etkileyen önemli
faktörlerden bir tanesi ne? İhtiyaçlar.
Senin buna ihtiyacın olup olmaması
önemli. İhtiyaç önemli. Benim seneye
mesela sizin 10. sınıf ara sınıfta bu
10. sınıfta yazılı notlarının olduğu,
genel tekrarlarımızın olacağı size böyle
ince bir ince ulaşabileceğiniz bir ürün
yapacağız. Bran branş. Bu senin
ihtiyacın olacak. İhtiyacın olunca da ne
olacak? Tüketim yapmış olacaksın. Başka
sadece ihtiyaç değil. Tamam hocam benim
bu 10. sınıfta yapacağınız ürüne
ihtiyacım var dediniz. Tamam mı?
İhtiyacım var ama ihtiyaçla bitmiyor.
Başka ne olacak? Senin gelir düzeyin de
burada önemli. Şimdi bu ürünü biz yaptık
seneye. Senin gelir düzeyin düşük olduğu
için bu ürünü alamıyorsun. Ne oluyor bu
sefer? Demek ki gelir düzeyi de senin
tüketimini etkiliyor mu? Etkiliyormuş
demek. Demek ki ülkedeki insanların
gelir düzeyi yüksek olsa rahatlıkla
ulaşabilecek mesela bu ürüne herkes. Ama
gelir düzeyi olmayınca ulaşamıyor. Ama
işte burada da devreye bizim
videolarımız giriyor. Olsun kitabı almak
zorunda değilsin diyoruz. Ne diyoruz?
videolardan zaten ücretsiz bir şekilde
bütün hepsini mesela bakın bu videodan
da ücretsiz bir şekilde ulaşabiliyorsun
gibi. Başka hah burada teknolojik
gelişmeye geliyoruz. Teknolojik
gelişmeler sayesinde tüketim artıyor.
Sen telefonla telefon var işte benim
yaptığım pazarlama teknikleri senin
önüne düşüyor. Ya da sen telefonla benim
videolarımı izleyebildiğin için
teknoloji gelişti. Ben de video yapıp
sana bunu izletebildiğim için sen de
buna ihtiyacın varsa ürünü
alabiliyorsun. Bak tüketimin arttı.
Başka reklam faaliyetleri. E reklam
faaliyetleri, tanıtım faaliyetleri fazla
olduğu zaman senin tüketme ihtiyacın,
tüketim kısmındaki hareketin hızlanıyor.
Moda da bunlardan bir tanesi. Trendlere
bir şey girdiği zaman, moda olduğu
zaman, "Aa bak ben de bunu almalıyım,
yapmalıyım gibi ihtiyacı hissediyorsun
kendinde ve tüketim ihtiyacın artıyor."
Yani üretim, tüketim ve dağıtımı ne
yaptık? Anlattık size. Evet. Bun. Burada
yazanlar gençler benim size
anlattıklarımın farklı şekilde
örneklendirilmiş hali. Evet bu konuyu da
bitirmiş olduk. Evet gençler bu konuyu
da bitirmiş olduk. Seviliyorsunuz bu
üniteyi bitirdik. Artık afetler
ünitesine geçebiliyoruz. Geçebiliriz.
Seviliyorsunuz. Ne diyoruz o zaman?
Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren. Bir daha
asla unutma. Zedua ile eğitim her yerde.